du sparst die bis zu hause so lukas echt
ich witzig allerheiligenberg empfand man
dass sie die ganze zeit geboxt und ich
fand das auch nicht witzig das einfach
weitergemacht
wir sind wieder beim turm und zumindest
und lukas irgendwo in der nähe und wir
machen jetzt zum wettrennen wer es
zuerst wieder in stadt ja derweil laufen
kannst über wasser ob david alaba bin
von kosmos
ich bin jetzt eine doppelte jetzt will
ich erstmal den doppelten ja du bist so
war ich habe mich so ein delfin
schwimmen job to job ich will am
liebsten einfach rennen halten das kann
ich gar nicht wenn bei 2.700 wird
wahrscheinlich eher zu hause
ich bin meist 600 habe ich hätte gar
nicht und nach vorne so ist das ist das
sind dann an oder ist das einmal so ein
normales ding du bist bei 2600 ja auch
bei 2600 jetzt ja ich bin meist 4300 ich
bin bei 4.200 her ist das iranischen und
sonntag
oder ist das so hier sind richtig coole
park erreichen
ok warte ich komme sagt eine koordinaten
natürlich muss das hochspringen delphi
modul weg die world at war nicht
geschafft macht er vielleicht gleich
oder geht schon mal rein und ich komme
die 1400 und 2500 wirklich kommen gleich
ok irgendwie stimmigkeit nur nicht nicht
schnell
ich weiß nicht warum und firma das
komisch
ich heiße haben schon jetzt sogar ein
stopp systeme gleichzeitig höre dann
müsste in meiner nähe sein
ja ich will man hört hier richtig
richtig weil gott mein gott mein gott
die unterhalten sich darüber
irgendwelche sachen wer da sind zu sagen
leute oh mein gott muss schnell ja ich
bin auf dem weg der smiles gerade da
kann es mal über seinen kopf ich werde
ich sterbe gleich geschafft das duo luca
bitkom schnell ich bin auf weg schneller
luca ich sterbe gleich egal angst dass
es nur so eine komische burg die
schaffst du locker nein wir sind voll
die patches traualtar ich bin auf dem
weg wo ich sehe dich noch nicht mal ich
bin vierter - 4300 per coupon an etwa
1700 sag noch mal - 4300 von 2700 g2 lg
zu - 4420 und 2500 okay siehst du da
nicht ein riesen burg nein mein gott
megawatt sind das - koordinaten gewesen
das erste ja - wie jetzt das zweite plus
koordinate richter ja ja dann muss klar
sein
ja vielleicht ist ja auch leichter keine
ahnung was ein donner 200 blöcke ich hab
bei az die zweite und dritte zahl
volltrunken abgehauen vielleicht kommt
da ganz oben auf mich runter gesprungen
wer weiß
du musst die jungs jetzt erstmal eine
box ohne burka fertig dass dir aber kein
name zunächst du gerade
ja
er ist nämlich nicht mehr den namen
immer noch nicht wer konkret liegt das
an den shader erwarte er muss schnell er
den namen siehst ja auch nicht wenn du
wenn du nicht mich direkt sie ist das ja
nicht sagte beez ich bin absoluter fotos
oder klar ist eine kleine insel davor
sagt einmal eine koordinaten patch -
4700 nein - wieder uns 400 ja da ist mal
etwas machen es schritt für schritt
kommunistischen burg schon wieder weg da
war keine koordinator war ja da war es
für mich wenn ich weiß nun auf der
falschen seite erfahren jetzt komm zu
mir her gefahren weil ich trau mich
nicht allein ich möchte es mit ihr
zusammen machen angefangen habe ich
schon mal ganz bisschen vor ich bin auf
dem weg ich muss er schwimmen hier wäre
ich dich jetzt halte was waren denn das
leben ist ja ich kann springt ein delfin
kuh so also du sagst du bist bei - du
bist bei 4.700 sechster ja und zwar mir
das richtig weit weg wasserspringen aber
ein boot mit ok danke alter wie weit ein
bisschen nur weg bauen und uns etwas ist
z lukas at ist 2800 2300 mal lieber was
gilt bei dir
lena ja in wirklichkeit nicht ernsthaft
du bist nicht zu hause stimmt ich bin
ich zu hause du bist du denn jetzt
du sparst die alte ist wir noch im
turnier jetzt allein machen bis du da
bist alter willst du so lange brauchst
ja ok aber erstmal ein ich komme mir
sofort nein ich bin dass du weg gefahren
auf der suche nach die alter ich bin
ihrem boot mit wo bist du jetzt jetzt
sagen ich dass du dich nach hause
gefahren bereit manhattan dann sagst du
wenigstens nein bin ich nicht ich bin
immer noch auf dem wassermann und wäre
ich koordinate 4800 nur 2800 4800 bin
ich gleich so und dann 2800 du hast gut
2700 warum bist du noch weiter weg bis
zu schlecht da ich will mit dir zusammen
was machen aber du bist heißt so
schlecht so schlecht mein lieber
also dann bleibt einfach mal wo du bist
ok da kenne ich gut bin ja eine
anscheinend erkenne ich war mir so ich
bin gleich bei dir 2700 der bin ich
gleich bist du auf ein komplett offene
meer das siehst du irgendein
anhaltspunkte ich sehe eine kleine
sandinsel ich bin zu sand in sin city
nein ich will mich bei 2.700 sagt genau
als 2850 kämpferisch noch kurz dann
reagierte sandte das gleich das
sicherstellen einfach auf eine insel ist
hier sind auch so ein kriegsschiff
siehst du das passt dabei direkt bei
2800 ok keks koordinate ich komme also
nichts zu suchen was ich mir ganz gute
verzauberung für den cirque du [ __ ]
bis zu hause luca ist echt ich witzig
allerhand welchem platz man dass du die
ganze zeit geboxt und ich fand das auch
nicht witzig wir es einfach
weitergemacht weil luca lüttmann bank
vor dir du kannst du nicht mein haus
rein weil ich das zu gebaut haben
verliert und darfst keine blöcke kaputt
machen du bist echt spaß die ich
versuche hier zu helfen ich hoffe dass
jetzt so heißt mich wohin da hat
versuchen einfach nur zu helfen
und du [ __ ] ich bin jetzt sinnlos
rumgefahren wegen dir bin weniger
sinnlos um gefahren weil ich dir helfen
wollte ich wollte dir helfen und dann
völlig sinnlos wäre
du hast mich vorhin folge schlagen die
ganze noch auf dem schiff aber den ball
nicht haben wollte ist nicht in dem
portal einloggen und da war ich dann da
war ich dann so klug und dann noch nicht
eingegangen
wenn ihr einfach abgewischt ich habe
irgendwie was verstehen wir spüren ein
trinken kaffee
ich hatte echt angst vor dir den und
dann versuche ich will ich mit dieser
und ding machen oder dann sagt so
einfach nicht ist nach hause aber nein
nein nein nein nein nein scale-out
obsidian broich dafür ob sie auch nur
gold auch das habe ich doch gar nicht so
viel brauchen das doof ist dass ich
hinten rum kreuze und dem weg nach hause
nicht finden
nett finden das ist das einzig der
elektrik stuff
magic johnson
stock
und dann sehen wir auch eine komische
dungeons auf dem weg und so weiter was
sind das für menschen die ihr leben
frage ich mich nur sorry dena
aber ich hatte echt ich hatte echt
wirklich mein junger mann ich hatte voll
angst wurde jetzt auf einmal da getötet
hat fast ja ja ja ja ja die noch über
alles reden können
meine freunde es ist jedoch so ein
riesiges fest
ich habe ein electric star ja ich kann
pflegen mama guck erkannt wir wollten
die sache noch aufteilen einer mine
kraft was wir wollten auch die sachen
aufteilen wie schnell die kaputt sich
noch schneller kaputt ist alter wir
wollten die sachen aufteilen und du
einfach verpiss dich einfach spaß die
festplatte fasst gegeben hätte was mit
dieser rüstung gegeben die ich nicht
brauche alter devise der elektrik
software kaputt ja mal eben schnell
kaputt gilt mensch luca mensch
management das hätte ich nicht erwartet
was für den emmy kaputt gemacht oder so
ich habe bayer hatte den neben wie
verzaubert oder sowas
na klar klar dass schnell kaputt darauf
was uns ja dieses unbreakable wir es
halt nicht kaputt ging heißt
aber trotzdem noch relativ schnell
kaputt ja das schon aber nicht aber
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser als
wenn nichts wäre schätze ich mal so
jedenfalls obsidian jannasch brauchst du
wohl wie kriegt der obsidian her alte
hol dir einfach aber nach wasser drauf
und fertig und schon hast du was den ich
möchte wird er das wieder deine stadt
geben jetzt ein bisschen angst sie zu
allen krieg leben
ja ich möchte sie sowieso erst noch im
sommer eis festung rad gesehen ich mir
die nummer 1 ich mal ein bisschen
sightseeing weißt du bei uns ist ja
altem und stege sind ja die besten
das heißt die machen alles die ganze
zeit schon sind so alle dann irgendwie
im umkreis weg und hier ist noch voll
viel was soll nach eurer stadt ist was
eine unentdeckt ist da kann noch weitere
level farm und so weiter macht viel spaß
gab es geht immer zu solchen level zu
fahren und dann zu machen darfst arbeite
ich nicht das wider was kaputt gemacht
wird
ja und ich durfte weil du hast gesagt
ich dachte ich habe sagte das portal
benutzen ist was kaputt machen darf doch
doch doch ich habe habe ich hab eine
aufnahme noch mal nachschauen ob du
sagtest ich frage lukas ich kann ihn
nicht durch ich musste aber welche
hätten soll dann muss ich hier durch und
dann darf ich ihnen ein blog kaputt man
hier durch ziegen um dich zu retten
und du sagtest ja nein
doch weil du angst mein leben hat es
letztendlich habe ich dann doch aber
dann habe ich gerettet
da habe ich angst du es mir gut geht wie
don quijote fast getötet danach hat ein
halbes herz und das immer neuen jahr
weiter geschlossen
ich arbeite habe ich nicht mehr auf dich
gezielt
du hast diese adels hierzu stellt gesagt
einmal richtig zählen hast ja gesagt da
habe ich richtig gezählt fast tot
und da ich verstehe auch gar nicht wie
kann denn das sein dass die sonstigen
legia bogen hast du ja ich bin halt der
barbie und das schwerter kann ok erst
ein bar wo er braucht ein guten morgen
ganz logisch handy ohne witz alter mit
was hast du denn alles verzaubert sag
ich nicht aber der ist echt heftig
gewesen war schon krass jetzt beginnt
die heftigste aufnahmezeiten und zwar
bei obsidian ab er kann es auf jeden
fall heftig was geht bei dir gerade so
ja ich laufe einfach nur übers wasser in
den wein beziehungsweise jetzt geht's im
moment kaputt und dann muss ich mit dem
boot wahrscheinlich weiter fahren es ist
richtig auf den euro in der heutigen
aufnahme kraft an ist schon kaputt
gegangen irgendwie angst dass ich
irgendwie das gleiche niveau entspringt
und es den tod bin ein bisschen in der
höhle oder brothers in einem haus ich
will wieder ob sie die an quelle
gefunden da so richtig will ob soziales
an quelle jetzt richtig viel obsidian in
dein in eurer stadt oder öl weiter
draußen weiter draußen das auch so ein
komisches portal wo ich meinen texten
habe ich auch gesagt alternativ boards
like you have
das heißt du bist du in dem portal
gegangen nach irgendeinem jetzt
irgendwie so ein großes nenner dingsbums
keine ahnung aber es sieht auf jeden
fall stark so aus als ob ich nie mehr
gewesen war
und ja ich hab einfach ich nehme jetzt
die zeit und bastian abweicht auch das
für meine scale rüstung weil alle
meinten bei twitter meines geldes von
twitter schied in der beschreibung
hast du wie lange die folgen aber ich
hab's nicht auf die zeit gekommen dass
wir nun sieben minuten geht die folge
noch 70 minuten ja das hat will ich so
bei welchen koordinaten bist du kommst
du da noch mal ganz kurz meine stadt
dass wir so ein friedensvertrag machen
naja ich bin jetzt bei oder möchten
keinen frieden mehr es ist egal ob ich
denke dass wir auf jeden fall cool weil
alles reden können wir die keinen
frieden hat für die ganze stadt machen
für uns beide so dass wir im krieg quasi
eine eigene
das war meine bedenken dass einfach lava
bis robert ob sie den abbau und wales ja
mensch und nur für uns beide für die
ganze stadt dürfen wir nicht sprechen
das machen ja nur die könige eben genau
wie können so ein privates ding machen
daraus zum privat und ich weiß nicht was
ich auf der stehen habe das ist kein
pickel das ist einfach irgendwie was
eine rote stelle irgendwie auf einmal
das ist einfach rot geworden würde hier
ist ich sehe das interface kann ist
einfach so roth auf einmal hier erst am
anfang der aufnahme war das nicht mal
ich hab keine ahnung was das ist fragt
herr tutorial stimme
roger hat sich letztes in euskirchen
verfahren woher weißt du hast jetzt
wollte ich nicht reagiert hat geschickt
normal ist alles gesagt man hat man
alles ist besser alles ist besser als
revisoren die neue version gemacht haben
davon habe ich noch nicht gehört mich
mal anhören
ich kenne irgend so eine version die war
geht so es ist besser als musik video
von ich richtig gut
aber ist das nicht meine schwester bild
entstand bild von den von dem blizzard
möchte wie viel habe ich eigentlich ab
von anita pleic versucht das galt eine
oberfläche des versuchs gardiner in
einer höhle 10.15 ich brauche 15 ich
habe 15 gut der oberfläche ich habe 15
aber ich auch gold altersklassen 8 bei
dir ja bei mir höhe komisch bei mio na
ja schlimm eigentlich wenn ihr so weit
weg seit er ist richtig geil wenn wir
eine andere tageszeit zu hätten ihm
darum habe ich das sehr gefragt weil ich
dachte das kann sein dass jeder fall
witzig aber das dann einfach nicht so
voll und könne nicht mehr schlafen gehen
ja ja ja stimmt das ja auch beziehung
aber mein tages rhythmus es sowieso
total kaputt dass das auch egal wäre ja
bei mir auch ich schreibe auch morgen
und übermorgen klose aber ich glaube
einfach ich macht wie den ich einfach
mein vater von dem vorhaben
und was für ein vorhaben das vorhaben
worüber wir volle aufnahme geredet haben
nevegal dass ich mach s secret of steve
kritiker niemand weiß okay dann stern
aber hast jetzt dann ob sie mittlerweile
zurück ja ja und was machst du gerade
becker ich jetzt noch so ungefähr 1000
locke ich hab noch voll an gebraucht
weil ich gerade noch so ein scheiß
dungeon angefangen habe aber es hat
nichts gebracht weil es vorzeitig
abbrechen musste ich hasse das ich hab
nur essen gefunden
ja ich kenne und so eine hässliche eisen
verzaubert hast du nie mehr nichts
bringen und man meint links geht richtig
schnell kaputt dieses der blöde psa ich
mache schon mal ein teil von der scale
rüstung einfach weil ich es kann
hast du nicht in eine andere richtung
als das ja ich hab schon triebel rüstung
dir ist aber schon fertig ja klein so
und da musst du trotzdem noch die andere
ist ja klar
man hat ja auch alle drei rüstung aber
dass man glaube ich eine rüstung
komplett geschenkt bekommen ja steht ja
doch alle richtungen echt ich habe meine
selbst die kraft hat auch alles geklappt
ich glaube ich bin gar nicht so schlecht
wie alle immer man das voll gut
eigentlich auch doch schon okay ich
brauche aber noch einige karl diamant
das bisschen traurig wieder obwohl ich
mein obsidian hingelegt ja ich klicke
einfach da rein
auch gut die am rhein
da muss ob sie dir bist du denn dort
noch gar nicht gold werde ich das
schönste aus in eurer stadt dann komme
ich mit einem ass wir hatten ja schon
mal seit ich ganz schön aber auch von
außen
ich habe ein anderes jetzt recht die
kaputte kirche
ich brauche sechs goldmann etwas besser
als gold mann zu sein brauchen wir
hatten wer kann den sechs gold haben war
nicht irgendjemand deiner stadt
vielleicht war es ja aber ich möchte
nicht einfach leuten was nehmen ja aber
du kannst du irgendwann zurück geben
also unserer stadt wäre es kein problem
das weiß ich bei uns ist was eigentlich
auch kein problem
ich lebe jetzt ein sexy carl diamond der
meinte letzte ovi sind bei deutschen
minuten
ja denn keine ahnung lecker lecker
mensch muss mit komme auf münchen dk
aber ist sich sicher wir müssen noch
teilen ja stimme ist jetzt eine neue
folge anfang alter schreiben sie mir
jetzt noch ins erstmal die aufnahme zu
beenden
wenn meine lieben freunde die folge ist
jetzt vorbei dann nämlich doch alle von
mit denen auf wo ich dann eventuell mir
einen mexikaner noch bei camping borge
und noch gold ging wie bei bombay oder
so und dann werde ich meine skepsis und
ich haben dann machen den und ich ein
friedensvertrag aber dann machen wir
wirklich frieden weil wenn du jetzt
nicht dann tötet oder so dann wäre das
so packe ich nehme gar keine items mit
wenn wir den friedensvertrag machen ja
meinetwegen vor allem wie es gibt ja
jetzt die regelung dass man leute nicht
in ihrem eigenen haus töten darf das
heißt gibt es die regel
ich glaube schon ich glaube sicher was
ich weiß auch nicht ja aber ich will
sowieso nur scheiße zinsen tauschen
diese hoffentlich ist jetzt nicht zu
lange waren haben wir jetzt beenden wenn
man 20 sekunden ich gehe in mein leben
freunde
vielen dank zuschauer 36 x mas coup